ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Hi, everyone.
Today we'll talk about
what's new with BigQuery ML,
and we also have
Demandbase with us
to talk about their
usage of BigQuery ML.
I'm Abhishek Kashyap, the
Product Manager for BigQuery ML
and Data QnA.
ERIC WHITE: And I'm Eric.
I'm a data scientist,
and I'll be
discussing two ways
that Demandbase
leverages BigQuery ML.
My colleague, Leo
Benkel, was originally
slated to present with me.
He did a lot of the
work behind this talk,
so I'd just like to note
that I will be presenting
his slides on his behalf.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Thank
you, Eric, for being here.
We'll start with talking
about what's new,
and then Eric will talk
about Demandbase use cases
with BigQuery ML.
To summarize, we have added new
types of models to BigQuery ML
to help you create many
more machine learning models
to address most of the use cases
that you would have for machine
learning in BigQuery.
Specifically, for classification
and regression models,
we have added the support
for creation of boosted trees
using XGBoost, deep
neural networks using
TensorFlow, and AutoML tables.
In terms of other
use cases, we have
added support for creation
of hundreds of thousands
of time series models
with a single SQL command,
and you can also now create
product recommendation systems
using matrix factorization.
For use cases that
require online prediction,
you can now export any
model created in BigQuery ML
and use it for online prediction
in Google Cloud AI platform,
or your own serving stack.
To set the stage, I'll spend a
minute talking about BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
enterprise data warehouse.
We have exabytes of
data stored in BigQuery,
and customers are able to
run SQL queries on petabytes
of data.
All of this is enabled by
the serverless architecture
of BigQuery, and
underlying that is
the separation of storage
and compute, which
has allowed our largest
customers to store
more than 250 petabytes
of data in BigQuery,
and the largest
queries being run
are around five
petabytes of data.
Now, this is awesome
for data analytics.
However, when you want to do
machine learning on this data,
we see a lot of tasks
which are not really
machine learning-specific.
Let's say you create a model in
a notebook on a sample of data.
That works well, but to
create a production model
we see the need to write ETL
pipelines for model creation,
and then you also have to do
ETL pipelines for predictions,
as well.
Now, bringing data
to machine learning
carries that list of tasks.
The bigger headache, however,
is that all of the governance
policies that have been
defined on the data just
go out of the window
the second you export it
between a model on a VM cluster
outside the query, which
I'm sure no enterprise likes.
We are solving that problem
through a SQL interface
to machine learning
called BigQuery ML.
With BigQuery ML,
we are bringing
machine learning
to the data itself
through two simple SQL commands.
One, you can say
"create model," and that
would build a model for
you within BigQuery.
And second, you can just say
ML.predict to use that model
and get predictions in
BigQuery All your features go
into the Select Statement,
so you can very, very fast
create models by
changing your features
and the model type
within that SQL.
We do automate a lot
of standard ML tasks,
like split-off training
and test data sets,
standardization of
numeric features
and coding of
categorical features.
So with a minimal
number of lines of code,
you can get a pretty good model.
And finally, since this
happens in BigQuery,
there is no
infrastructure management,
and all the governance and
access policies you defined
are automatically applied
to these machine learning
workloads as well.
To recap, we are
extending BigQuery ML
by support of all these
new model types, which
should enable you
to address most
of the machine
learning use cases you
have on BigQuery data.
To give you an example
with a time series model,
one of our developer
advocates, Felipe Hoffa,
wanted to predict how many Stack
Overflow tags would be there
for each of those.
And while doing that, Felipe
created 15,000 different times
series models in 20 minutes.
Each of those is hypertuned,
so we actually ended up
creating 600,000 models
within 20 minutes,
without any
infrastructure management,
without any data ETL.
Another example of a
capability we have brought on
is the addition
of AutoML tables.
AutoML tables was created to
build a best-in-class machine
learning model on
structured data,
without any feature
engineering, and without having
to think about which
network architecture to use.
AutoML tables searches
through a set of architectures
and builds the best
possible model for you.
AutoML tables has been
available to its own UI,
and now we have added it as
a model type to BigQuery ML.
So just like you can
create an [INAUDIBLE]
model or a logistic
regression model,
you can now create an
AutoML table classifier
through the same SQL
interface, and very easily
build it into your data and
machine learning pipelines.
Now, all these are being
used for a set of use cases
by many of our customers.
To give you a few examples of
the most popular use cases,
let's start with
the retail industry.
The use cases we are seeing are
creating product recommendation
systems to send products
through emails, which
are very personalized
for the end users,
calculating the propensity
to purchase or propensity
to click on an asset for
each customer, and again,
using it in marketing campaigns.
If you want to forecast
demand of a particular product
or category by store or by
region, with time series,
you can now do that in
a single SQL command
and use it for better
merchandising and supply chain
optimization.
And the fourth one is
doing customer analytics
by easily creating
customer segments, a.k.a.
Personas.
When we look at
logistics and CPG,
the use cases we are seeing
are estimation of the time
a package will be
delivered, or when
a vehicle will get somewhere--
predictive
maintenance, prediction
of how much inventory
of a product
would be needed at
a certain warehouse.
For financial services and
insurance, on the retail side,
we are seeing usage
in calculation
of customer LTV, which can
then underlie all business
decisions for each customer.
We can improve the
underwriting process
by easily predicting loan
default probability at the time
of receiving an application.
You can use BigQuery ML for
the batch credit card fraud
with fraud detection
pipelines that run overnight.
And finally, there are use
cases in anti-money laundering,
as well, where you can
forecast how many transactions
may be stopped for AML checks.
The fourth vertical, which
is media, gaming, high tech,
has use cases similar
to retail, where
you want to recommend content
to an app on the website.
Or you want to predict
player activity,
you want to win a
game difficulty.
Similarly, you may
want to predict
if someone is
going to subscribe,
or if someone is going
to churn, and take
a marketing action accordingly.
Now, all these use cases can
be solved through BigQuery ML
with the new features
we have added.
To walk you through an
example, a lot of our customers
join data from multiple
online and offline sources,
and create a Customer
360 profile in BigQuery.
Now, this Customer
360 profile primarily
contains behavior
data, transaction data,
and demographic data.
You can now use all
of these together
to create a set of customer
segments right within BigQuery
by using kmeans
clustering, and we
have customers who are
doing it on hundreds
of millions of their customers.
And once you have those, you
can build recommendation systems
in place and run
personalized campaigns
to each of these customers,
again, staying within BigQuery
and using BigQuery ML for
these machine learning tasks.
In terms of pricing, if you
are a flat rate customer
or you use flex slots, you
can use your slots as-is.
There is no additional charge.
Each time you build
a model, we just
use the slots you have
already purchased.
If you are using auto limited
tables or a model type which
uses cloud AI platform
in the back end,
we convert those resources
into slots at price parity.
If you use BigQuery On Demand,
the cloud AI platform cost
is built as a
pass-through to BigQuery,
so there is price
parity there, as well.
For models which are
trained natively,
like time series, matrix
factorization, and regression,
the pricing is according to
the amount of training data
that we use.
With that, I'll
pass it on to Eric.
ERIC WHITE: Thanks, Abhishek.
And thanks to Google for
giving us the chance to speak.
Again, I'm an Eric, and I'm a
data scientist at Demandbase.
I'll be discussing two use cases
where we leverage BigQuery ML.
The first involves our
digital advertising products,
which consists of training
a model on massive amounts
of data at scale.
The second use case
has to do with how
we took a fairly complicated
Spark model that runs on demand
and converted it to
run in BigQuery ML,
and ended up with quite a bit of
savings, both in time and cost.
So I'll provide a little more
context for each use case
before diving in.
But first, a little
bit about Demandbase.
We're a late stage startup.
We have offices in San
Francisco, Seattle, New York,
and London, and we have
raised over $100 million
in venture capital.
We consider ourselves
an AI-first company.
We process the
world's business data
to help marketing and
sales organizations,
and our customers include over
100 Fortune 500 companies.
We offer a SaaS platform
for orchestrating
account-based marketing
strategies, which
includes a targeting
solution for advertising,
an engagement solution for site
optimization and customization,
and a conversion tool to align
ABM initiatives with sales
teams.
We have a strong data
science and engineering
team, all of whom are quite
active in the GCP ecosystem.
So the first use case
I'd like to discuss
involves our targeting
solution, which
is effectively a B2B digital
advertising platform.
We use AI to optimize
delivery of digital media
to all accounts in our
customers' ad campaigns.
We provide full
transparency when
it comes to advertising
metrics, such as media spend,
click-through rates, account
reach, et cetera, which
means we're held
accountable to delivering
the highest-quality
inventory that
leads to clicks, engagement,
conversions, and so forth.
We process roughly 430
billion options per month,
and we've bid on those
auctions around the clock--
an average of 50,000 bids
per minute, which means we're
bidding on nearly a thousand
auctions every second.
So just to give you a sense
of the size of this data,
again, we're bidding on nearly
a thousand requests per second,
and each bid request consists
of thousands of features.
For example, this person here
visits her favorite news site
during the day.
We know the IP address
of the request.
We know the company she works
for, right down to the location
of the office and geo.
Whatever site she's
visiting, we know
the publisher, the
amount of inventory
on that page, the position
of the ad, et cetera.
And finally, there's all
kinds of additional data,
such as the exchange,
the type of auction,
Deal ID, and so forth.
On top of all that, we could
have dozens of our own customer
campaigns that qualify
to serve that single ad
during that visit, so
we also need to work out
which ones to serve.
To do so, we use a
click-through rate model
that essentially takes
all these features
and predicts just how
valuable that option is,
what the likelihood
is that it will
lead to a click, et cetera.
And this scoring and
decision-making all
has to happen within several
milliseconds for each bid
request.
So initially, we
did all our data
science in local
Jupyter notebooks,
meaning we'd export
the data out of
BigQuery in a Python notebook
for analysis, training,
validation, et cetera
in scikit-learn.
Besides being inconvenient,
limitations on the size
of the data, CPU, memory, meant
that we had to down-sample
the data--
not just the number of
rows, but even the number
of features that were
considered for the model.
So it's no surprise that
with such a high cardinality
of features that this would
affect both the calibration
of the model and its accuracy.
Since our data already
resided in BigQuery,
we decided to use BigQuery
ML, namely because it solves
these issues and,
as I'll show next,
training a logistic regression
model is just trivially easy.
You just point your
model at your training
set, no matter how
many rows or features,
and BigQuery ML takes care
of [INAUDIBLE] coding,
k-fold cross-validation, and
everything else under the hood.
So it was much more
convenient, much faster,
and because we no longer had to
down-sample rows or features,
we actually saw
significant improvement
in the calibration of the
model and its performance.
So just to show
you a real example,
this is how you train a
logistic regression model.
It's really as simple is
writing a short SQL query.
You can see the table name
is bid_requests.training_set.
You name the model
whatever you want--
in this case, model_name.
Specify the model type--
logistic regression,
in this case--
add a parameter for L1
regularization, and that's it.
When it's done,
you save the output
just as you would any table.
And that table, which
is really a model,
can then be queried
for validation,
or to make actual predictions.
There are a variety of
things you can control.
If you want to do
multi-class classification,
or if you want to standardize
or scale your features,
it's all available.
So this is what we did.
This is how we moved
off of Scikit Learn
and onto BigQuery ML.
So what if you wanted to
try a different model,
let's say a deep neural
network, for example?
Almost nothing changes
except for the model type,
and in this case, how
many layers you want.
Other than a physical limitation
of 512 megabytes, I believe,
you can have as many layers
and nodes as you wish.
So in this case, I
specified three layers
with 256 nodes, and two more
layers with 128 nodes each,
and that's it.
Just press Enter and wait
for the training to finish.
So with deep neural
networks, you
have similar options
as logistic regression,
but also ones specific to
neural networks, such as batch
size, dropout rate, et cetera.
We also tried XGBoost, which is
sort of the hottest algorithm
around since random forest.
Again, you can see that very
little is changing here.
Same training data set,
just a different model type.
In addition to parameters
specific to XGBoost,
such as the booster
type, it also
supports L1, L2 regularization,
and other options.
There's even a boost
to tree regressor
if you want to do regression
instead of classification.
Just change the model type.
So we've seen how to train
three different models.
How do we validate them
once they've been saved?
The answer is, once again,
as simple as a SQL query.
You've saved your
model with some name.
Just select the precision
recall F1 score from that model,
just as you would query a table.
This makes it very easy to
inspect validation metrics,
understand feature
importance and what
was important to us was
being able to access
the coefficients of our model.
What's really cool is that these
validation metrics can also
be viewed as interactive
dashboards that are built right
into BigQuery UI.
So yeah, it's very cool stuff.
And I should mention
that the XGBoost model
did have the best F1 score--
ever so slightly better than
logistic regression and DNN,
but overall comparable F1
scores across all three models.
So the second use
case is for a solution
we call account selection.
Basically, a
customer provides us
with data, such as keywords,
describing their business,
buyer titles, or a list
of existing customers.
We use AI to identify
companies with strong buying
signals for that customer.
Our account selection model
trains terabytes of B2B signals
and intent data, and
effectively generates
a ranked list of accounts
that your company should
target next.
Because our customers
will prioritize
their entire marketing
and sales cycles
with this list of companies,
it's incredibly important
that we get this right.
Customers should be able
to update their profiles
and relaunch account selection,
which basically trains
a new model and generates
a new list of companies
for that customer.
The way we initially saw this
was to build a model in Spark
and use on demand clusters,
which were not only costly,
but would cause issues
when the job failed,
because a new cluster
had to be provisioned
from the marketplace,
which increased
the time and the
cost, et cetera.
So a new model has to
be trained whenever
a user pushes the button.
This means that
we have to support
hundreds, if not thousands,
of jobs per week,
and the cost was something
like dozens of dollars per job.
In terms of size, the features
include intent keywords,
company firmographics, job
titles, and other B2B signals.
Basically, thousands
of dimensions
that we reduced using techniques
like matrix factorization.
We previously stored our data
in all kinds of disparate data
sources, from Postgres to
static files in the Cloud.
In terms of time,
starting a cluster
and then training
the Spark model
typically took up to 40 minutes
for each job to complete.
And when a job would
fail, a new cluster
would have to be started.
We would occasionally take
several hours for a single job
to complete.
So along comes BigQuery ML.
We decided to replace
our Spark random forest
model with a logistic
regression model in BigQuery ML.
This was not without
its challenges.
For example, we had to
either move our data sets
into BigQuery, or
at least copy them
as temporary tables in BigQuery
to build the final training
table.
This means all the
feature engineering
has to be expressable as
SQL statements or UDFs.
So for example, if you
use the cosine similarity
between vectors as
a feature, you'd
have to express that as a query.
Our approach was to build this
pipeline as a dependency graph.
So what do I mean by that?
Basically, we've
created a data pipeline
entirely out of SQL queries
in BigQuery, organized it
into a graph.
So any extraction
transformations,
feature engineering,
et cetera, we
express as a directed graph
that creates temporary tables
at each step.
This way, if anything were
to happen during the process,
we wouldn't have to run
the entire thing again.
It would just pick up
from the temporary tables
and then continue to run
the pipeline until we end up
with the final
training data set.
So I've already covered how
to train a logistic regression
model, so I'll just jump
to the final output.
Basically, we end up
with a ranked list
of companies that have greater
likelihoods of becoming
a future customer.
I do have to note
this screenshot was
lifted from our website.
This is not real data
being shown here.
And again, because our
customers' entire marketing
and sales cycle could be
based around this list,
it's essential that
decisions made by the model
are explainable.
The first thing a
customer will want to know
is, why did you
include this account?
Because BQ ML makes it easy
to extract feature weights,
for each model, we are,
in fact, able to make
explainable statements
like, well, this account
is similar to an
existing customer,
or has a strong intent for
keywords in your industry
or whatever.
So for this use case,
we've been running
the model in BQ ML
for months, and we've
had zero failures,
which was amazing.
Previous average times
of up to 40 minutes
to run the job now take closer
to five minutes, so the time
to create a new
list for customers
was reduced by a factor of 10.
If you break down the
costs-- and again,
we've actually never had any
failures with BQ ML to date--
the cost is now basically
only a few dollars
per job, which means a
cost reduction of over 10x.
So overall, BigQuery ML has
been a huge game changer
for Demandbase,
not only improving
the accuracy of our model
in the first use case,
but saving us a factor of
10x in both time and money
for the second use case.
So we absolutely plan on
continuing to leverage
BQ ML for our next
generation of machine
learning models at Demandbase.
Thank you very much.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Thank
you, Eric, for your time.
These insights were
extremely useful.
If you want to learn more,
we have a Coursera course
that will teach you how to use
BigQuery ML with some code labs
using Qwiklabs.
They use cases that are shared--
we are building template
Jupyter notebooks,
which we are hosting at
the link I'm sharing here.
And finally, if you
decide to use BigQuery ML
and have any questions
or feedback for our team,
please do write to us.
Thank you for your time, and
hope you have a great day.